hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast application of the novel
cell proliferation biomarker in cancer
drug development immunoassays of
diabetes penis one in in vitro and in
vivo studies of hematological and solid
malignancies presented by Martin Shaw he
is a business development manager at
eres el ap I am Marjorie Torres of
laggards and I will be your moderator
for today's event we are delighted to
bring you this educational web seminar
presented by lab Reed's lab roots is a
leading scientific social networking
website and producer of educational
virtual events and webinars before we
begin I would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the ask the
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop down box that appears on the
screen what answers many questions we
have time for at the end of the
presentation if you're trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation please click on
the help desk button located in the
promotion board at the bottom or center
of your screen or use the ask a question
box to let us know that you're having a
problem this presentation is educational
and thus offers continuing education
credits please collect on the continuing
education credits tab located in the top
right corner of the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming
Martin Shaw I will now turn the
presentation over to him sharing our
time with me the presentation I'm going
to make now everything is in the public
domain but since it is a commercial
company I ever to make a statement
regarding financial issues and that is
that this presentation may include
predictions estimate or other
information that might be considered
forward-looking while these
forward-looking statements represent our
covens judgment they on future trends
they are subject to risk and
uncertainties which could cause actual
results to differ materially you're in
excuse me your caution not to place on
June reliance on these forward-looking
statements which reflect our opinions
only as far of this state
of this presentation so I haven't got
the legal out of the way we can now get
to the interesting bit I'm going to
present on improve stays and lignin
seized with a novel proliferation
biomarker thymidine kinase one it's
going to be quite a long presentation so
I'm going to break it up into sections
first of all I'll talk a little bit
about what our tumor bio markers then on
thymidine kinase one is a tumor
biomarker then it's application teams
logical England lignin C's then solid
tumors then in vitro drug studies then
on it's assay and then summary in
discussion as I leave each part I will
be making a slight repetition of the key
points so I'm not forgotten myself when
I repeat things is quite intentional so
first of all what are tumor biomarkers
and then I'm going to talk a little
tickle operation biomarkers so tumor
biomarkers any substance that is
associated press of a tumor is a tumor
biomarker and most serums human bio
markers indicate tumor mass such as
armed with CEA PSAC a 15-3 beta to mark
governing and many more but there are
very few serum biomarkers of cell
proliferation and our hypothesis is that
and while we're interested in tk1 is
that most current tumor biomarkers
measure what has happened the past rate
of change such as doubling time or the
current situation such as tumor mass or
white blood cell numbers what really
matters is the tumor growth
and proliferation biomarker is important
in measuring tumor growth as I mentioned
and you can use this information to
stratify patients and subjects you can
use it to age of choice of therapy for
example if the tumor it's got a low
proliferation index maybe you should
wait watchful waiting or use less
aggressive therapy and if it's high then
you should use more aggressive therapy
and furthermore many cancer drugs are
toxic or of side-effects they're
expensive and it's a chance they would
drive to more resistance so you don't
want to use them necessarily
information biomarkers are available
today on mostly heme you know
histological biomarkers and the gold
standard is called ki-67 and there's
also PCNA and the one I'm going to talk
about most for the rest is presentation
tk1 these are all proteins that are
expressed during the growth phase of
cells and they are the percentage of
cells which stain for these biomarkers
is the proliferation index and provide
an indication of the current cell growth
but there's certain problems with them
first of all they quite biopsies that
are invasive and they only show the
states of of a small part of the tumor
and they have a low reproducibility
because their opinions
so there is a need for a biomarker that
indicates the total body activity of the
malignant disease there is applicable to
a standard serum sample that can be
determined with a routine analytical
method I'm we're going to propose that
the serum thymidine kinase one measured
using an antibody against the tk2
tension as the potential to be such a
biomarker
talking about what tk1 is 70k one enzyme
activity has been used at the
established proliferation biomarker
mainly females logic malignancies for
about 35 years
it's been studied in many types of solid
tumor which I'll come to later on
presentation and when it tk1 is used in
eminence the logical staining it is
highly associated with the gold standard
proliferation biomarker ki-67
what does it do Simon kinase one is
involved in DNA synthesis it couples
phosphates to Simon into makes a midi
mono phosphate which is a key step in
DNA production and this is the reaction
which is involved in the commercial
assays for tk1 activity and tk1 is
released from the cells to annette
turnover and eventually ends up in the
body fluids so that's their introduction
to the proliferation bio marketing
thymidine kinase one now a little bit
first application in solid tumors which
I'm going to come back to later on it's
enzyme activity in the tumors is high in
most forms not all but now going on to
the first part legs part of step
presentation tk1 activity name it's
logic which malignancies here's a
summary of its elevation in different
specialty of hematological malignancies
as you can see it's elevated in most
forms of hematological malignancy but
the extent of the elevation varies from
malignant the legacy time to legacy time
what you can do in the Hamptons
malignancies you can use it to study the
disease you can use as a discriminative
disease stage it can provide
prognosticator
information it can aid in studying
therapy response and relapse and in
disease progression
look at the first part of this clinical
staging here is a study on non-hodgkins
lymphoma and as you can see as this
volume of the tumor increases the serum
activity of farming kinase one increased
as well so there's a good agreement
looking at chronic lymphocytic leukemia
another some of heme solid malignancy
this is the association of the t k1
enzyme activity with the disease stage
but using the RAI staging system and you
can see that as the stage increases the
level of t k1 in the serum increases and
interestingly the solid circles all
cases where the disease is a very slow
course so-called indolent disease and
there you can see that it's solid the
squares are ones which were initially
thought to be indolent but then later
progress and you can see that these are
somewhat higher than the ones which stay
in the vent
so it seems to be prognostic as well
looking at making prognosis here you
have a study on chronic lymphocytic
leukemia and there you can see that the
ones which have a low level of TK one
that's below seven I'm going to have 50%
light live for about seven years whereas
the ones that you have a high level 50%
if only for about eighteen months so
it's a very strong prognostic indicator
yet you have similar in non-hodgkins
lymphoma and here again the ones which
have a lower level they have a game at
fifty percent chance of living about
seven years whereas the ones you have a
higher level have a fifty percent chance
of living eighteen months or so so again
is a good prognostic indicator looking
at disease progression here is a study
on acute myeloid leukemia and here is a
change in tk1 serum activity in subjects
with different outcomes
the top two are subjects which survived
during the period of the study and you
can see that the tk1 level Falls after
therapy and stays low the bottom to
offer subjects who died and there you
can see that there is a rapid increase
in tk1 activity prior to death so it
does seem to be a monitor of disease
progression
an important part of biomarkers is that
they combined different biomarkers show
different things and the combinations
usually could provides extra value
comparing combining serum tk1
with other biomarkers it seems in some
cases that the serum tk1 activities
reflect a combination of tumor mass and
proliferation rate you get some idea to
total number of cells divided growing I
should say it can also the serum tk1 and
value correlates with the proliferation
index which is the measure of cell
growth and it also correlates with the
peripheral blood lymphocyte count this
would give to give some idea of the
tumor burden
so it's a very useful biomarker in
studying therapy response tumor growth
can be used well combined profitably
with other biomarkers so why is it not
been widely used and this the state of
TK 1 in serum has got much to do with
this because intracellular active TK 1
is a tetramer
the serum TK 1 exists as complexes of
different sizes and enzyme activities
and some sera contain TK 1 inhibitors
and serum enzyme activity essays may
underestimate serum TK 1 then the gold
standard assays for TK 1 utilize
radioactive tracers such as a
radioactive tritium or iodine commercial
assays may require specialized equipment
but immunoassays can solve these
problems so matt'll very briefly talk
about the amino acid ethylene kinase 1
and our comeback is again more fully at
the end of the presentation as I
mentioned TK 1 in serum II comprises
complexes of different sizes and
different enzyme activities but they all
Express the TK 1 sorry the TK 2 10
antigen here is a FP LC study of enzyme
activity against molecular weight in a
fraction of serum and as you can see
there's two peaks one about 720 kilo
daltons and one of the round solid
around 100 and these fractures have
different enzyme activities but they all
Express the TK 210 antigen as can be
shown by western blotting
the essay itself is a simple microtiter
plate sandwich eliezer it utilizes
multiple antibodies against the a unique
amino acid sequence on the tk1 monomers
the TK 210 antigen an important it's a
unique pre acid treatment releases TK 1
from the serum TK 1 complexes and
exposes the TK 2 in engineering science
it gives a very good correlation with
the gold standard radio essays of TK 1
activity and looking at the diagnostic
power of 2 k 2 10 Eli's are compared
with the TK 1 activity assays in
leukemias you see that the diagnostic
power is very similar the area under the
curve for the TK 210 concentration it's
not put in 84 and for the TK 1 activity
is not 0.79 with very seminal cement
sensitivity and specificity so this
means that you can base so you can
relate results with the amino acid to
the traditional historical data using TK
1 enzyme activity assays looking forward
in studies and hematology here is a very
preliminary study on tk1 tk2 tenet serum
concentrations of protein you can see
that in subjects or controls the ones
with the green and then when you have
subjects pretreatment it's somewhat
higher and then during treatment the
results are more variable generally a
bit higher and then in subjects in
remission
it returns too close to normal so it
does seem that we have got proof of
principle that this assay can be used in
human social malignancies and that the
data can be compared with the historical
methods based on enzyme activity assays
so looking at it in excuse me looking at
hematological malignancies tk1 is a
biomarker for self registration
difficult word to say serum levels
reflect disease activity TK one Canadian
patient or subjects for classification
commutes make prognosis can be used to
monitor disease progression edge
information to stands perform with other
biomarkers that can be used in many
malignancies it's a standard microsite
réaliser
gives a good a great agreement with
clinical results based on tk1 enzyme
activity it's an open system and it's
ciment I'll now go on to another field
which is tk1 in a study of solid tumors
and we can discuss your comments on him
so teaming exists at the end as I
mentioned previously tk1 is elevated in
solid tumors most of them here is a
selection
and it also seems to be that the
expression of tk1 in these tumors is
related to therapy response for example
a high tumor tk1 activity was this
marker of core clinical responsibility
oxygen therapy Sadie's possible that tk1
can aid in therapy selection in solid
tumors a nice research idea so why is TK
one not being widely studies in solid
tumors back to this one again you've got
this TK one is present in syrian stable
aggregates of many molecular weights and
enzyme activities as I mentioned they
all expressed the TK 210 antigen but
many of the TK one aggregates in samples
so lead human subjects are enzymatically
inactive although they express the TK
210 antigen and here you have an example
of this from a subject with prostate
cancer if you look at the enzyme
activity based on the FPL c
fractionation you can see that the
hollow circles are the normal the active
is in the normal subject and then you
see that the activity that the prostate
cancer subject is the somewhat low
molecular weight but look at the bottom
and look at fractions 14 one words you
have a lot of TK 1 there based on the
Western blot studies but there's no
enzyme activity a lot of the TK 1
activity sorry a lot of the TK 1 protein
in solid tumors serum from solid tumor
subjects is enzymatically inactive and
so is underestimated using enzyme
activity assays repeating again the
Caeser so is a standard microtiter plate
Eliezer but to emphasize here there is a
unique pre acid treatment the breaks up
the serum tk1 complexes and exposes the
tea-table 210 antigenic sites
and you can see that this increases the
diagnostic sensitivity si if you look at
the TK 210 concentration the sensitivity
is about not 0.5 in the area under the
curve is about nine point nine on the
same subjects looking at the enzyme
activity the sensitivity is only about
nine point two six and the area under
the curve is only nine point seven nine
so in these breast cancer subjects the
TK to ten little eyes it was about twice
as sensitive for detecting the TK one
the TK one protein
I mentioned combining tk1 with other
tuber biomarkers and here's a study on
breast cancer the blue line is the CH
15-3 biomarker and then the red line is
the TK 210 but then when you notice the
TK twos and maybe somewhat more
sensitive but then if you combine them
you get a better result still and I
think this is where tea table 210 TK 1
immunity is very part when it combines
with other biomarkers there you can come
aggregate this an indicator tumor mass
with an indication of tumor rate of
growth there's another subject in
prostate cancer and here you can see the
comparison with a form of PSA called Pro
PSA which is suggested as being more
sent more accurate indicator prostate
cancer than the normal total PSA and you
can see here that the the red line is
the Pro PSA the blue line is the TK 210
some a very similar power and then the
green line is the combination which is
better still
so it's a sign so it's very valuable to
combine Tek to ten without biomarkers so
summarizing the TKTS analyzing solid
tumors the eros otk to ten eliezer
measures tk1 forms missed by enzymatic
assays the TK to eternalize have better
discriminate between healthy controls
and subjects with solid tumors could be
used to study many types of tumors as
information to studies perform other
biomarkers and it see marked so that's
the solid tumors and that's a
description of the use of the TK 210
Eliezer in vivo and you and I hope I've
convinced you that it's a very valuable
addition to the study of malignancies
I'm not going to talk a bit about drug
discovery and the potential role of
thymidine kinase eliezer in this
preclinical evaluation of novel
compounds in cell culture is a key step
in drug development
and the assay of TK one with the arrow
TK to tune Eliza offers the potential to
study antiproliferative effects in vitro
here's a study where we have lies
leukemic cells and compared the amount
of tk1 released with the number of cells
and you can see there's a good agreement
correlation I should say now looking at
the response and this is a bit complex
but um bear with me here you can see the
effects of the drug doxorubicin on a
culture of leukemic cells and you can
see that as the concentration of
doxorubicin increases from zero to about
not point one the intracellular TK to
ten TK one concentration increases and
then decreases with the high doses and
at a very high doses is the TK one is
released into the culture supernatant
this is very similar to what is seen in
in patients where the administration of
drugs that affect the synthesis of DNA
or cause DNA damage seem to induce TK 1
and this is reflected in the fact that
using positron labeled finally defending
deal derivatives in PE T scan you can
see that the tumors seem to flare before
they get with the early stage of therapy
so what I can say is that the induction
particularly low doses in drug cultures
seem to be similar to what's seen in
vivo and this means that TK when I said
with the TK 210 Eliza is a potential
translational biomarker because the
results that are seen in cell cultures
seem to be similar to that which is seen
in vivo
you
so they are now seeing the applications
of the US immunoassay of TK 1 in vivo
and in vitro I'm now going to be very
briefly present the assay method itself
and to go through this first a little
bit about the challenges of tk1 and then
the procedure itself a little bit of
performance data bit on sample stability
a bit of further information I'm in
discussion
as I mentioned the molecular weights of
serum tk1 complexes and the specific
activities differ between normal and
Jewish subjects and some tk1 aggregates
and certain subject for solid tumors are
enzymatically inactive but they all
express the TK 210 antigen as I
mentioned in hymns logic malignancies
the distribution of enzyme activity and
the presence of the TK to date 1018 is
quite similar so you get a good
correlation with the results from enzyme
activity assays but in subjects with
solid tumors where a lot of the teacakes
one may be enzymatically inactive the
Eliza is more sensitive
so it's very important that you the
pretreatment of the samples the brakes
the t-coil tetras from their high
molecular weight complexes any
explosives the TK 210 antigen using the
pretreatment through the sample diluent
and this gives solid greater sensitivity
for solid tumors and also it gives you
more consistent results between subjects
with different types of malignancies
so that's the reason why the SI is more
sensitive now coming into some of the
methodologies as I mentioned previously
it's a microtiter plate sandwich
analyzer using monoclonal antibodies
against them unique amino acid sequence
to Tk 210 and importantly again a unique
pre acid treatment releases the t k1
from the serum complexes i exposes the
TK 2 to nitrogen excites here you see
you had the pretreatment you add the
sample to a microtiter plate code with
an t TK 210 the green antibody you then
add a second antibody second anti TK 2
identity label with biotin as the red
and then you develop the color using
streptavidin labeled horseradish
peroxidase a very standard microtiter
analyzer is for the it's got a good-ass
a range it's sensitive it's dissolved it
gives linear dilation it's very precise
and it's stable so you can have the kid
in a refrigerator waiting for samples to
arrive the samples themselves TK 1 is
quite easy to work with
it's got a stability room temperature 24
hours so you can handle it quite easily
it's then stable file 4 degrees
centigrade so your shipping is my should
not be a problem and then you have good
stability when frozen so you can do
retrospective studies or collect samples
until you've got enough to make the
assay feel to make it practical to run
the assay as i mentioned in employed
your differences you have good
correlation with the enzymatic assays
and similarly you have a good diagnostic
correlation with the enzyme active
assays in to insert in hematological
Magnus's by in solid tumors you could
grow much better sensitivity then
compared with the traditional methods
it combines very well with other
biomarkers we are now starting to
publish articles based on it's a safe so
to conclude a long presentation tk1 is a
biomarker for cell proliferation serum
levels reflect disease activity in your
beautiful patient subject classification
prognosis monitoring disease progression
can be used in many malignancies
tk1 is different forms in solid needs of
local malignancies an enzyme activity
acid underestimate tk1 in solid tumors
but the RSL TK 210 Eliezer measures all
forms of serum tk1 there's good
agreement with clinical results on TK
one enzyme activity in hematological
malignancies greater sensitivity of
solid tumors more comparable results
between types of malignancies it's a
standard eliezer procedure positive
synergy with other biomarkers applicable
to in vitro models an open system in a
see marked so the era so TK to turn
Eliza are more another biomarker cell
proliferation which is a mesh is what
really matters the rate of cell growth
it expands and simplifies a study of
cell proliferation there's new
opportunity to Cancer Research and thank
you for listening to me it's been a long
talk I now put I make the meeting open
to discussion thank you very much for
your attention
you
I finished thank you Martin Shaw for
that informative presentation we will
now start the lateral portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now you click
on the ask a question drop down box
located on the far left of your base
window asking questions into the box
that appears on your screen and click on
the send button well answer as many of
your questions as we have time for let's
get started our first question is do you
have any data on xenograph um we have
data that human tk1 can be measured in
Mouse serum because the mouse tk1 has
got different immunogenicity to human
tk1
when you measure the TK 210 antigenic
sites so we know that is chemically
possible but we have no data showing
where they can be used to study the two
studies integral in mice if anybody's
got such a study in mind I'll be very
pleased to hear from you so that we can
do something together thank you without
our next question is why are so few
recent studies on TK 1 I think this is
because the assays based on enzyme
activity would avert a long time ago and
based on their limitations the research
went as far as it could now the amino
acids have been developed I think you're
going to see a new interest and they
were we had also now started to publish
data using the immunoassay of TK 1 using
the TK 210 antigen and I think there'll
be many more published in the near
future thank you for the answer I laugh
I noticed that the cut-offs between
butter and pour processors differ
between malignancies any comments I
think this is because different types of
malignancy of different proliferation
rates and also they're found in
different age groups for example chronic
lymphocytic leukemia instead we found a
very old people and we have
which is that the age range is 40 k1r a
specific in specifically not elderly
people so I think this based on the type
of patient and the agressivity of the
tumor I would like to once again thank
one star for his presentation but I'll
just like to thank lab roots for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through May of
2018 you'll receive an email from lab
roots letting you know when this webcast
will be available for replay please
share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now thank you
for joining us and we hope to see you
again soon
goodbye